last year I made the trek to visit the
set of the Huntsman winters war and as
expected the sets were massive the
costumes were incredible but what
surprised me is how much fun the cast
was having a lot yes while filming such
a dark tale
it was literally a partay and we now
have the outtakes to prove it oh my god
oh is that what was that this gas could
not stop cracking up the Huntsman
already had us with those costumes
Charlie's in the epic scale who knew
there was so much laughter behind the
scenes finger in your nose it's been
heaven actually to be around Shelley's
and the sisterly bond we've managed to
achieve offset has sort of translated
onto camera I got to do most of my stuff
with with Emily they reek of it I've
basically become a single white female
I just I'm completely obsessed with her
my fake nipples ever looks like Emily's
cried I've been friends with her for a
few years and just a great sense of
humor great attitude credibly talented
but all out fun never-before-seen clips
are part of the film's release on DVD
Jessica I think we we have a good amount
of banter back and forth I was not
it's what draw the sisterly at times
charli's of course played the evil queen
but she also excelled as a working mom
her four-year-old son Jax was on set and
you can hear him in one of the clips
Doc's Mama's working oh you got to go
out then if he can't because Fitness Jax
was full of surprises when I visited on
the set
Charlie shared another priceless mommy
moment he came to said today and he was
watching a rehearsal and he turned to my
mom and you just went mama
spicy it actually threw me off a little
bit because they were having so much fun
they're dressed alike that that's all
they were dressed I'll call it spicy
through you well mom was always spicy